[Applaudissements]
il fait que citer les autres je sais que
laurent ruquier nous regardent et ben je
lui dit laurent j'irai moix tout de
suite dit des conneries que tu peux
faire beaucoup de reproches à yann moix
n'est pas dire qu'ils étaient nuls
alors c'est quelquefois un peu
incompréhensible là il était en terrain
conquis il était avec des écrivains
christine angot michel houllebecq il va
falloir ski voir ce qu'il donne avec des
politiques là ça va être plus
intéressant parce que froid qui donne un
langage un petit peu plus accessible et
bien pensante arrêté qu'il est nul
tu peux lui donner toute la terre n'est
pas clos chemin le choc